i don't know how good looking this 12 year old
is but everyone just falls in love with him
welcome to episode one the pilot episode
optimistically of she doesn't read the news
with me chris turner and me your wife yeah she
can't talk without me saying she has permission
you may talk i give you permission for the
next half an hour to talk as much as you want
darling thank you so much i'm so appreciative
for all the things you do for me um just this
is a bit by the way i do not wield the hand or
something cuff links into my belt that's in tenet
we watch tennis and it's very confusing i didn't
watch ten i walked out but one of the highlights
is kenneth branagh putting his cufflinks in his
belt so when he's going to whip elizabeth drebecki
she's going to be diana in the next series of
the crown um it will hurt her more um we should
give you a behind-the-scenes peek before we kick
off we are recording this in my wife's family's
gym we have a gym room which is very exciting
and i went downstairs to get a lacroix because
obviously and uh your dad was roaming around
the house heading this way in his gym clothes
and i said i'm so sorry we're recording and
he said can't you do it somewhere else and i
was like uh we have to do it now really because
you know otherwise alice is gonna get tired and
he went but i just had my coffee oh so he just
had a coffee to get himself all hyped up and
caffeinated so he could do half an hour in the
elliptical half an hour on the rowing machine
and we've not let him come in
here but it's for a good cause
sort of a king lear situation playing out there
just noticed i've got ink on my hands that's a
macbeth situation isn't it out damn spot uh so
just so you know because this is the first time
in uh she doesn't read the news basically my wife
does not read the news no that makes me sound uh
very stupid um i just think it makes people
unhappy i think that's true i think on balance
i'm a less happy person because i read the news i
think i mean someone clearly has to read the news
we can't all not read the news i think it's a bit
like how we can't all be buddhist monks but it's
nice that some people are out there being buddhist
monks i'm the buddhist monk in this scenario the
whole idea is i'm gonna tell my wife the biggest
news stories of the week uh and then at the end
she gets to tell me one thing that she's learned
uh this week not from reading the news but from
reading she's a reader so uh to kick us off
though i'm gonna give you guys and her my
my news updates for the week i've had a i've
had a good week i've been doing some shows
doing some virtual shows uh did one for
a university a kind of involvement fair
where i had to talk about all of the activities
that were available and introduce various people
one of the awkward moments was when i introduced
the asian american association and the man in
charge of the zoo called cut to an asian american
student who then looked to the camera when
that's not my organization and then they had to
cut someone else who was then the representative
of the organization and it was very tense and i
could not help myself from saying awkward which
i think is not what i should have said it doesn't
help it does not make things less awkward i did a
bat mitts for this morning bat mitzvah is uh a bar
mitzvah but for girls and for those of you that
don't know bar mitzvah is a celebration for the
the coming of age of jewish children that's when
you're 12 or 13 as far as i'm aware and uh i i was
trepidatious about this i thought this was going
to be quite a tough gig i had to get up really
early a audience of 30 13 year old girls isn't my
ideal demographic i don't know if uh anyone's
heard me talk about my youtube stats pretty much
95 men um and it went remarkably well i had
a lovely time the the girl celebrating was
was wonderful very very fun um the best moment of
it was someone in the call left their microphone
on just as it was about to start and we heard the
most stereotypical domestic row that could ever be
heard over zoom where it was just a dad shouting
at his wife presumably just going i told her she
could watch it here she's moved the laptop she
can watch it here see what i have to deal with
and the phrase see what i have to deal with is one
of my fav i don't think i've ever used that in a
domestic dispute no but i think you really
should i feel like you're missing out on a
on a trick there see what i have to deal with
um so that was that was my week it was it was
you know chill it was good um i didn't usually on
those gigs for teenagers i'd rather than come in
and say hi i'm a comedian i say hi i'm a youtuber
right because teenagers i mean i think a youtuber
to a degree is a bit like being a pop star which
i mean chris is not a monster sadly for both of us
but um yeah i think i think it is like a
viable career path they perceive in a way that
is hard for us to imagine yeah they've started
asking if i'm a tick tocker i have to i have to
go a take water some type of clock and they go
ha ha he's so old um do you talk uh yeah i talk
sometimes i tic i i didn't tell them that i'm on
youtube this time because my latest youtube video
is a pro foreskin right rap and so i didn't
want to rock up to a bat mitzvah and be like
sup guys check out my latest video all about
how foreskins are great don't chop them off
um it includes the the line uh i know a lot of
jewish guys get the snip tell the rabbi thanks
guy you can keep the tip that's quite good
it's a great line but i don't i'm not i'm not
overly keen on this video why i find it a lit
a little bit of vulgar you find it objectifying
i think the stock footage you used of the
hot women was uh yeah a little a little bit
objectifying yeah she was very um scathing about
the fact that i included hot women in my product
to get people to pay more attention to it but then
it's a bit hypocritical that you've let me put you
in this podcast oh baby so sweet so sweet um if
you haven't heard it you can check it out on the
youtube channel i will put a little a little clip
of it now you can hear a little sample of it now
foreskin i've got a foreskin just a heads
up baby it's a warning i wanna make sure
cause i've been burned before when i show
them my foreskin they show me the door
girl i hope you've got an open mind cause my
dick's just like god designed i've got a foreskin
girl let me be blunt there'll be a little
bit more going into your however long that
snippet was there rest assured we sat here for the
exact same amount of time just in loving silence
so to get on with the news the news this week
there's it's it's been a historic week it's a
momentous week it's a week which made me think
we should start this what you'd know the biggest
event of the week right you know what she's she
doesn't really lose but she's not i will tell
you what happened earlier this week which
is that um i i follow this guy on instagram
who makes 18th century garments and as i was
looking through his um feed he had something like
everyone like deep breath for tomorrow
historic day and i was like i wonder what
that is so i was like chris what is this 18th
century garment maker saying about tomorrow
and chris just looked at me and he just went the
inauguration alice and i was like oh this is how
oblivious you are a person who literally lives
in the 18th century knew more about modern modern
politics than you no no okay all right that was
a low point um but so the inauguration happened
biden is now president not my president that's
what a lot of people say well are they still
doing that they're still doing that yeah they
think that um the plan is you don't need to be
a member of the the house to be speaker of the
house and so in two years they predict there'll
be a red wave where republicans will win back the
house can then elect a speaker and they'll pick
donald trump to be the speaker which would then
put him third in succession they'd then impeach
biden and harris which means that donald
trump would then become automatic president
that's very elaborate it's very clever which is
why they're like don't worry we're not going to
impeach by now we'll have to do it in two
years when trump's speaker of the house
as far as i can tell impeaching presidents doesn't
seem to have much of an impact on whether they
continue to be presidents not really not so far
there was a poet a young a very amanda gordon
young poet laureate did a poem and lady gaga did
a song yeah that's and joe biden not drew baiden
sorry bernie sanders were like a hilarious um i
have something on later outfit and everyone made
memes so alice is very aware of the memes that
went around right bernie had some mittens that
were knitted for him for his campaign trail by
a teacher i think it was they were recycled uh
several of my raps this week have been inspired by
bernie's mittens people who asked me to rap about
those it was very memorable i think meme of the
week and that's not going to be recurring segment
we're not doing meme of the week i'm not one of
those kind of people um but yeah the integration
it was a paired down affair so question because
um i remember when trump got inaugurated there was
like all this stuff about um you know did anyone
show up some people said yes some people said no
uh presumably you can't have a big group of people
right now yeah so when trump was inaugurated he
was like it was the biggest attendance ever and
then the national parks released photos being like
it was not and he was like oh it's because
they put white coverings down it show
people show up against it worse which would make
sense because his fan base is entirely white
and it's actually not true not true of course
sorry attempts at humor in this podcast will be
shot down by my wife women aren't funny you
see yeah the inauguration was scaled back
however star power pretty impressive right he had
i mean i i did get a list of the people who played
at his inauguration right the foo fighters katy
perry demi lovato bon jovi tom hanks hosted it
bruce springsteen was on it loads of people lady
gaga was there obviously right the funnest thing
was to compare it to trump's celebrity attendants
because he had do you remember who he had um did
he have three doors down he had three doors down a
band that are they are they still abandon i don't
i thought they must have like reformed sure are
they like 20 as good as panic at the disco is that
kind of their situation i think they were they
were sort of like um no i can't i can't really
i don't know any of their songs yeah i do actually
what are their songs kryptonite how does that go
okay yeah one of my joke i wrote
but never performed was superman
won't indulge in nocturnal necrophilia he won't
go to the crypt tonight he's pretty good at it
okay all right but i want to say something
about this so a while ago um sort of twice a
month i go on buzzfeed just to see if i'm old
yet and you take a quiz that says are you old
click these disney princesses we'll tell you how
old you are what kind of chair are you um no so
we should point out that again if you're watching
this um alice is in quite a nice chair and i am on
a chair that frequently breaks i've been doing
live shows and i've had to do extensive kind of
core squat strength to stay up because this
chair's gone crack and i've gone oh mate you
drop a mic at the end of a rap you don't drop off
a chair in the middle of it carry on sorry um so
i i read this buzzfeed article that it was like
famous celebrities you didn't know were actually
republican and then it had this list of 30 people
no one has ever heard of i mean just really they
were scraping the barrel just searching for anyone
you know mildly famous who they could claim was
republican and the only thing is and i know i know
you're about to make fun of the republicans for
this and be like lol isn't it funny that trump had
no one famous and biden had all the famous people
but i can't help but feel that one of the big
problems between the left and the right is that
the right feel that the left is smug and a big
part of that is that hollywood et cetera are all
left wing no i think that's true um i think aliens
there definitely are republican celebrities who
hide it chris pratt came out as republican and
people like jumped on him um and the fun thing
there was all his marvel co-stars defended him
and it was like quite obvious that well when all
the kind of female members of the mcu and let me
be straight couldn't give a [ __ ] about the mcu
the marvel cinematic universe oh yes so all those
superhero movies that have essentially ruined
cinema by making every big movie a superhero movie
that's that um everyone defended him but they
didn't defend you know all the other i don't even
know their names because again i don't watch the
the films some of the things from the integration
so they had high-end security measures because
obviously like a couple of weeks before we had the
so some people kidnapped some people the capital
was stormed no i knew that i didn't know that
i thought but there was also a kidnapping thing
wasn't there someone crashed gretchen whitmer
had an attempted kidnapping plot in about july
of last yeah that's all right that's still pretty
good um the michigan governor i believe um so they
had about 25 000 national guard troops and they
all stayed in the capital and one of the scandals
i'm sorry say that number again 25 000. so but um
there is a pandemic on now so how are they how are
those um are they all just sort of diseased
now yeah i think i think so i think it was
so the the problem with that was they made them
sleep in the garage how big is this carriage it's
pretty big have you seen american cars they're
huge i don't think it's big enough to fit 25 000
people there was there was a bit of a they weren't
all in the capital but there was a big scandal
because they were made to sleep in the in the
garage and aoc sent a tweet out saying hey anyone
who wants to sleep in my office um come we've got
biscuits and you can imagine showed up oh my gosh
i would have second i would have put on camo and
being there like hello i'm a national guard can
i sleep in your office please aoc um oh she's
an absolute babe one notable non-attendee was
uh was was trump there no trump didn't go
is that allowed it's allowed it's the first
time in like 150 years do you know who the last
person was who didn't show up so trump is only
the fourth person to skip it out of 45 and the
last person to do it was andrew johnson in 1869.
i think abraham lincoln is killed five days
after the end of the civil war and then i believe
andrew johnson takes over from him andrew johnson
assumed the presidency as he was vice president at
the time of the assassination of abraham lincoln
yes but the thing is he was vice president but i
believe he was of a different party from abraham
lincoln so abraham lincoln was a republican yeah
he was a democrat who ran with lincoln on the
night and bear in mind obviously so republican
back in the day meant like almost the opposite
of what a republican means now um and so yeah so
that's you know he kind of was going against a lot
of what abraham lincoln had set up you know so he
he went and like directly undermined quite a few
of lincoln's early reconstruction things so yeah
a similar a similar vibe of a president following
someone who was um politically and ideologically
opposed to him so he he didn't show up to ulysses
s grant's inaugurations there yeah so ulysses s
grant was was a republican i believe we mentioned
andrew johnson and i uh will have edited this bit
out but i got a little bit confused with andrew
jackson and andrew jackson was uh i think either
censured or impeached by when he was president
and well he was quite a trump-like figure so in
the oval office you get to decorate it when you
move in right you get to decorate the white house
trump famously um put gold rugs and gold curtains
in so i have a question what is a gold rug is it
stiff is it a gold sheet is it it's a gold colored
rug all right yeah like you have golden hair
it's not made of gold good explanation thank you
uh and he made the curtains more gold than they
used to be and biden coming in has switched
the office back and there was a big picture
of andrew jackson on the wall and he's taking
it down and put franklin or someone on um and
one of the big scandals this week scandal is a big
word is that trump had a bust of winston churchill
in the oval office and biden's taking it out yes
because winston churchill has had a pretty sharp
turnaround in the last what 15 years i would say i
would say up until 15 years ago it was on problem
it was considered very normal to think of winston
churchill as a hero and i really think in the last
like it feels recent that has switched and people
have started focusing a whole lot more on on
his sort of is it genocide the famine he yeah in
india killed a lot of people i think three million
that's a lobby it's quite so when you really
add it up it's more than i've killed yeah
yeah we'll leave it at that we won't give you a
number but it's more than that um so he's taken
out and apparently so this happened when when
obama was in office he took the busted church
as well and trump put it back and apparently
boris johnson who's churchill's his hero he's
written he's written biographies of churchill
he he's very angry he's angry just funny
because in picture and angry boris johnson oh
adorable he's so sweet he's such a sweet little
angry man he's so harmless you'd never think
he's up to any ever could he do anything he's
so bumbling our final thing we'll say
about trump there was a threat on his life
is that true do you know that's a new thing
no but this time is a bit more real um iran
the the leader of iran or if not the leader you
know there's i think iran has like two leaders has
the supreme leader you don't sound as if you're
speaking with a great deal of confidence on the
screen i think ayatollah khamani uh he tweeted out
on twitter um a picture of a fat man golfing shot
from above with a shadow of a bomber like over the
golf course and then in farsi it said we will have
vengeance [ __ ] twitter is so embarrassing
you guys like death threats used to be cool
do you know what i mean like it used to come in
these anonymous envelopes like with anthrax now
it's just [ __ ] twitter how embarrassing i mean
it's pretty he immediately got banned by the way
the guy's account because all the trump fans were
like what so trump gets banned and you won't ban
an actual death threat um he did get that doesn't
seem fair you should probably ban i mean the whole
twitter my god um okay so so this dude in
iran wants to kill trump i mean i maintain
that doesn't seem like do you know why they want
to kill trump wasn't there a big world war three
almost thing about a year ago yeah yeah so
um let me try and recap what i know of this
so um it was before covert it was like the biggest
no i know so the reason i know about it is in all
the covered recap videos everyone's like remember
lol when we thought it would be world war three
and then it wasn't um and so no i don't remember
anything so his name was kassam solomani and
he was a top military general egypt this week
there was a big news story from egypt something
did happen in egypt some people are going to
go to jail because they had a birthday party
and their cakes were a little salacious they had
a baker make some cakes with buttocks and boobies
and willys on which for americans are asses
titties and uh [ __ ] um and there were photos
on social media of people like eating these cakes
like it's got a willy on it and they've cracked
down because in in islam it is against against the
religion to have cakes with genitals on and when
specifically this is a quote from the economist
when questioned they could not point to where
in the quran it said that no but i think the quran
does say that you're not supposed to create images
of exist like nature like that's why so like
in in mosques and things it doesn't have like
you know paintings of muhammad it has instead it
has like shapes and geometric patterns people are
going to go to jail because they had some willie
cakes that seem a bit extreme doesn't it does seem
a bit extreme but this is the country that you
know they had a me too movement because people
accused certain big figures of molesting
them and harassing them sorry men were
molesting people i know it's shocking only in
egypt though we managed to contain it and um
they arrested the men who did it but then they
also arrested the accusers and the witnesses
there was a big thing in russia alice
now you you definitely know this
what happened in russia well in
1917 there was a very important
so in russia do you remember the the man got
poisoned they poisoned his tea which is the most
underhanded okay look i actually don't feel to
blame for this it's very hard to keep track of all
the people that russia poisons which one are you
talking about we have met some people that russia
personally met people who russia is
well one person that's not that's not
nic we um wait what let's not exaggerate okay
cool she speaks fluent french and it pisses me
off it's yes anyway but go on say it's a it's
a bone of contention as you would say in france
um so they they poisoned uh navalny who is a
critic of putin and the leader of the opposition
party and wait i do know something about russia
didn't an american man fly over to russia
i mean i'm sure it's happened at some point
wasn't there like isn't there some kind of guy
my mother was talking about this and she said he's
a republican and a hero uh which is surprising for
her because she's you know she's very very
anti-republican but um he the russians hate
him and he flew to russia anyway so this i think
you're talking about the same person so this is
navalny who is hate putin and putin hates him he
made a big video called like the the biggest bribe
or something which is all about how putin takes a
lot of money and gives it to all his cronies putin
really does look like a bond villain doesn't he oh
yeah i mean it's not have you ever seen the page
where he's in a submarine that's on its way down
and he's just looking out for the little submarine
hatch and it just looks as if he's just this
bond villain like leaving at the end of the film
to return and the next one like he's so he is evil
looking but like quite hot very scary man i
put him so one year i made my brother a um a
calendar of hot villains from history and
i had quite a sexy picture of putin in it
who are some of the others do tell well i think
the obvious one is we've all we've we've all
wanked over stalin right young stalin is young
star old star i don't even mind that mustache his
hair he must hit maybe it's just a good picture
that's you know some people say that uh young
stalin was [ __ ] hot the thing with stalin you
know he was very good at getting rid of pictures
because he used to erase people out of pictures
when he killed them so they don't they don't
exist anymore yeah i don't know that that was that
was the i mean he was the real winner i gave him
december because that's you know yeah who are
some other hot villains because i think people
are listening to you being like you better not put
hitler in you didn't play i didn't put hitler in
i'm sorry hitler not not because of his politics
he just wasn't a fitting well he wasn't yeah
he was no oil painting but he did love
oil painting he didn't really actually
prefer watercolors ceausescu yes yeah cha
cha chancheski was the yeah i think the in
bucharest he was the romanian dictator yeah yeah
right right right some baddies who were baddies
because baddie is slang term for attractive
yeah yeah since she's a baddie never heard
that well it is are you sure yeah where did you
find it on tick tock urban dictionary that i'm
gonna add now before you get a chance to check
it he's returned they immediately arrested him
they he recovered in germany for five months
from being poisoned he immediately returned
they immediately arrested him and they've been the
biggest protest against putin in russia uh since
putin came to power since then and the russians
have just treated it by putting everyone in jail
in the uk uh where we used to live there they've
had been a bit of worry recently because obviously
they're in quite a big lockdown at the moment and
they're planning on doing that until mid february
because and it snowed and it did snow that's
that's the news that alice knows is from our
what's up group where someone sent a photo out of
their window and said it snowed i think i'm up to
date on most of the important you're up to date on
them yeah yeah oh it's cool so the most important
thing there is there's a lockdown because there's
a variant in the uk off kovitz yes it's much
much more contagious much more contagious
one of the policies that leaked this week
and ministers in the uk some of them agree some
of them don't and let me see what your thoughts
are and if you can spot the flaw in this strategy
we're proposing to give everyone who caught covid
a single one-off payment of 500 pounds now this
is on top of the money that the government has
been giving people anyway obviously i think
three million people who are self-employed
have still been left out are they trying to pay
people to get coveted they are paying people
to get covered that's the big flaw in the plan
well i don't understand so what what is the um
argument they're saying if you've got covid
we need you to stay home for two weeks
and stop going out and spreading it and a lot
of people who have coveted are still going out
because they need to earn money to live right yeah
they're saying we'll give you this money along
with universal credit and the other welfare
schemes that they have which are not enough
stay home but the floor and the plan is people
then were like brilliant well who's go it's like
those um chicken pox parties right where kids
oh you've got chickenpox everyone come around
and have a bloody rave and then you rub your kid
against another kid and that sounds horrible i
guess you could make the argument um sorry i got
distracted by a rogue cat so we have the cat here
we're now on to a segment that i'm inventing
and i'm going to call australia news going on
dan and dap um we we love australia we've been to
australia a couple times the australian government
has said to google that they need to start
paying the people whose news they aggregate
so google like you know we'll put a news story
we'll like you know on your search results we'll
give you a news story from a website and you
might read the news story directly on google
goodbye cat the australian government have said
oh mike you've got to you've got to pay for that
you've got to pay royalties the only reason
for this section is that you like doing your
australian acceptance yeah you're not doing an
australian accent enough i can't you know i can't
the australian government has said to google you
need to start paying royalties otherwise we're
gonna you can't be in australia and google said
all right yeah google said all right well you can
do an american accent for google they're american
what's google said uh no i don't i don't know what
i've google said what do you think a massive tech
corporation have said oh yeah we'll pay you money
they said they're gonna pull out of us yeah they
said you don't get any google then god so they're
all going to be using yahoo i mean i guess so
australia for years didn't have netflix or amazon
and to be honest they were probably fine we'll see
what happens maybe next time we go to australia
we'll be like i don't know let me google it
and the police are gonna be like oh excuse
me mate now you have to bloody big it you've
got to bring it australia uses verbs in a very
funny way and i can imagine that oh bloody
being god he's a proper being so uh bing
bing crosby that's where it comes from i
don't think so where does bing come from
it's just a nice sound is it nice is that
what it is yeah google yahoo google ding yahoo
ask dreams the alice is so british that that's
the only one she uses oh james would you please
i don't want to ask anyone but my valid
when i have a question about how to get to
nando's nando's you've never beaten us you've
never even i have eaten another okay name three
sizes uh they have fries curly fries and cheese
fries probably balls rubbish macho peas mate i
have been and it was actually quite lovely i have
to say yeah what um what what chicken did you get
i don't eat chicken as well you know you don't eat
chicken oh don't eat chicken um so we've we've had
we've had the australian segment it was a roaring
success that's going to be coming back for next
episode um this this segment this little thing
a little bit i'm inventing it's called breaking
news it's a news story from today so it's even
less likely that you'll have heard it um my
breaking news story today do you know who jojo c
was different from jojo who sang get out right now
you know she was 14 when she sang that really
she was go on is that the jojo it's only a year
away from the people who wrote my bat mitzvah
um i could have had jojo there no jojo c well
you don't know who jojo siwa is look i i tiny cute
blonde girl wears massive hair bows oh the massive
hair bow girl yeah okay wait so let me tell you
what i know about her um recently people made
fun of her for her massive hair bows so then
she started wearing not massive hair bows and
was like actually there's more to me than my hair
voice okay so the news article that i learned this
from led with jojo siwa famous for her massive
hair bows so she's not really managed to rebrand
herself that much away um the breaking news about
her is and she's beloved she's got like 10 million
instagram followers she's like she's from a show
called dance moms as far as i'm aware and i think
that's quite a popular show watched by everyone
um and the big news is that she has just come
out she did it by posting a picture on instagram
or twitter of her saying my cousin just bought me
a shirt and the shirt says best gay cousin ever
and i think people were confused they were like
is that your cousin and they're really arrogant
they're like yeah wear this um i mean look i have
merchandise available such as the 9th century
crop rotation hat and t-shirts they dropped the
beat good sir and it was just my nephew's birthday
and i did send him a chris turner t-shirt to wear
um that's a lie i sent him a kiss t-shirt because
he loves kids obsessed with kids absolutely legend
uh okay so she she came out um as uh as she hasn't
come out yeah it's sort of unclear now i feel like
i feel like if you came out 10 years ago everyone
was like well you're a lesbian but if you came out
now people are like you could be non-binary
you could be yeah we could just be sort of
there's like so many different yeah she's come
out and she she just she just said hey guys are
great women are great people are great and then
obviously the replies to her tweet suggest that
people are not great people are massive pieces of
[ __ ] but i do think that that's the kind of like
because i think she has a very wide appeal i do i
think she has appeal with people who would usually
not not know gay people yeah exactly so i think
that's actually really um i mean quite brave of
her because i i could imagine that that could have
a negative impact on her numbers or you know what
it will have it'll it it may shift her audience
right because she might lose some numbers and gain
others right other people will be more interested
in her but uh still i mean that must be she's like
a teenager how old i think she's 17 yeah i mean
it's so difficult being 17 to begin with add to
that having to come out to 10 million people what
a [ __ ] night yeah i mean one of the things i'm
worried about with this podcast is by coming out
as having a wife i'm going to lose a lot of all
the ladies who love watching me and they're
like oh he's not single this is disgraceful
chris really you know to preserve your mystique
you ought to be sexually available at all times
we've had the week's news and that's all the news
that you don't need to know anything else that's
all the news that happened it's time for your news
because you don't read the news but you do read
so what i've said is you get to tell us
something that you've learned not from the news
but from reading this week so the floor is yours
educate us i i have been reading a lot of uh
medieval um english romances so uh i'm gonna tell
you a little bit about king horn which is horn
now before you get too excited he is a child yeah
so king horn king horn is one of the earliest uh
middle english romances he's often put in the same
category as other romances like somebody clarify
romances which means stories um well yeah well
sort of that's a complicated question romances um
you know it comes it came from france um eleanor
of aquitaine brought um basically troubadours and
the idea of chivalry over from france just assume
that everyone knows what aquitaine troubadours and
chivalry are um uh but yeah so a medieval romance
it's not like you know it's a love story there is
usually elements of a love story in it uh but
it's a story about knights basically it's about
this prince called uh prince horn who um he
his his island is invaded by um just wicked
evil saracens they're just so evil these are
the saracens are well it's sort of unclear in
medieval literature theoretically they're muslims
right it's the crusades but um the way that the
saracens are described shows a really only passing
understanding of what islam is and it's just other
right it's just different from us all we know
is they did not have cakes with genitals on
definitely none of those but so um the saracens
these evil wicked saracens come and they uh burn
down all the churches because they're pagans
and they kill all the children in the land
and they kill the king but when they get to horn
he's like 12. and he's so fit he's so attractive
that they're like wow we know that you're going to
grow up and be really angry at us for destroying
your island and killing your father but we just
can't kill you're just too handsome so instead
they let him and a coup like couple of his friends
go on a boat and he gets on a boat and he washes
up on a different shore and um this king of this
new island sees him and is like holy [ __ ] you
are so han like wow he like i don't know how
good looking this 12 year old is but everyone
just falls in love with him um so he gets adopted
and um then various things happen he falls in love
with um riemann hill the princess of the court
but he's betrayed by his cruel friend fickenhald
uh anyway so he ends up killing tons and tons
of saracens to prove his love for rivenhilld
how many i think he kills at least a hundred
in one afternoon because in these romances
essentially the knights are superheroes this was
the mcu of the past that's actually a quite a good
analogy yeah absolutely thank you that'll be your
dissertation if you are doing an english degree
write a dissertation on why medieval romances
were the mcu of their time well it's also very
related to sort of fan fiction or i mean
it just it all plays into each other right
you might read a romance about gawain and be like
oh i like that bit of gawain so i'm going to take
gawain and add him into my story about you know
also it's like dc versus marvel that he kills
hundreds of saracens in one afternoon even though
he's uh apparently 13. um he's very small they
can't like get him they're like slicing over
his head and he's down there at one point he's
like messy he comes back to his island and the
saracens there are like oh we should have killed
you but you are just so hot um and so then he
kills all of them and then he becomes uh king
of his island which is called sudanese um which
so he's actually pseudonym i don't yeah i don't
think so what a twist at the end boom i don't
think he is sudanese but yeah it's a weird island
um and he marries roman hild and lives happily
ever after oh that's not well thank you for
teaching about king horn obviously i am renowned
for my freestyle raps and people often ask me
they're like oh doesn't isn't your wife lucky
that she gets freestyle raps all the time isn't
she we're going to finish off with a freestyle
based on any of the topics that we spoke about
today we're definitely including king horn what
else would you like me to wrap up so king horn
um andrew johnson not going to ulysses s grant's
inauguration boris johnson being angry about the
winston churchill bust being removed uh jojo
siwa is more than just hair bow girl yeah
and russians choosing to poison people
using adorable cozy methods like cups of tea
great here we go wide mouth slap jaw like a
yawn when i see a fit child and i call him king
horn now i better make clear everybody agrees
he's the most handsome kid that can ever exist
only 13 king amongst all the men see their little
horn slaying all the saracen get the scimitar
cutting off their knees then he goes gets his wife
she'd be like jeez you're so attractive and you
caught all the people revenge on them now they're
equal coming for a sequel gonna do killing if you
sit there with the beverage chilling watch out for
the russian creeping up behind you alexi novony we
find you and so we take a little bit polonium put
it in your milk you go down now killed by the kgb
now the fsb now putin coming over in your
mouth with the poison you should always be
aware i can kill everybody like a riding a bear
but alexi survive no perishing five months later
he arriving on a plane in russia he like let's
go back home and stand against putin in moscow
clapton iron they threw him all away bye
bye russian accent no more with you our play
take it out of there like a churchill bust clean
it up nicely none of that rust trump put it back
once obama removed then biden came out he's a
very old dude he was like oh i'm not into you
mr winston you killed them in india how many three
million three million it's not on time not b i'm
killing them that's okay though get it out put
it in storage boris johnson couldn't ignore it
he's like wow this is totally outrageous come on
tropido should do me a favor put it right back
what do you say fighters like i don't care about
the uk yeah you guys are on your own try and
understand you did the brexit just a lonely island
and that's not a reference to comedy rap groups
talking about this jojo siwa with the big hoops
and a big bow but it's not just these she came
out online people start jia ring at her and saying
oh i don't lie anymore and she's like i don't even
care i don't adore all the haters see you guys
later the beats gone over that please do me a
favor remind me what the latin was that we need
to do oh yeah ulysses i'm done with you we fit you
in right here at the end andrew johnson not your
friend because he didn't come immigration did not
attend you were there standing outside the kappa
all looking for andrew peering at the mall saying
yo johnson where you gone eh bro you should have
showed up mr aj and he was like no i don't fancy
that you're republican and i'm democrat i was
the party of lincoln i'm the vp but then he got
shot in his head t he and obviously he's happy
because that raised him to power which is what
kamala harris thinks will happen in a few hours
um there's that's a good punchline to finish off
i'm not saying kamala's going to kill joe just
saying that you know when he dies she will be like
oh that's bad news anyway let's uh let's put that
busted churchill back in i love him she's actually
part indian so she would not well i wanted to say
i'm actually i just want to check i don't think
i'm 100 sure about that number three million so
don't quote me on it how many okay let's have a
look the 1943 famine in bengal killed up to three
million people that's a [ __ ] ton of people all
in bengal i'm glad you didn't cheer then i thought
you were gonna be like yes no because you got it
right and then i would have cut it out and be like
where's the church to kill three million people
yes listen to our podcast uh yeah no that's that
just in bengal [ __ ] that's pretty bad yeah
i mean india's massive yeah but it's huge
like there's a lot of people in bengal sure
i'm not saying that's i'm not saying it's a good
thing i'm just saying that's you know that's a
huge number anyway i knew the number so i i guess
that's good i clearly haven't have been taking in
the searing facts of the last century yeah so i
mean anyone who's interested in um learning more
about you know all the obscure stuff that my wife
knows about you can follow where can we follow you
well my instagram is where i review my books uh
at let them eat books with underscores instead
of spaces you can so go ahead yeah find her on
there and i am obviously on chris turner comedy on
instagram and chris pj turner on youtube do give
this a subscribe we'll be putting some out weekly
um and if you go to the youtube if you've been
listening this you can watch this as a video
there'll be a link to the video podcast of this
as well alex thank you very much for hanging out
with me you are beautiful it's a pleasure i love
you very much and thank you for that handshake
um hopefully one day you'll let me kiss you on
the cheek don't hold your breath see you guys next
week